hi guys and welcome back to rapid fire
language learning today we're exploring
the question how to watch movies
in a foreign language and i have three
pieces of advice
first watch movies that you have already
seen if that is the case
you will enjoy the movie more you will
understand the context and
you are gonna watch until the end
because you already know that you have
seen that movie and you like it the
second piece of advice is to watch a
movie with subtitles in the target
language or watch a movie in your target
language
with subtitles in your target language
it's a little bit like listening and
reading at the same time
and you're not cheating you're actually
making your life much easier with
comprehensible content and the third
piece of advice is that if you're bold
enough and if you have
energy and will make sure that you watch
a movie with some
sort of note taken device or maybe a
notebook so that you can jot down all
the interesting pieces of information
and words
that you come across if you do that
language
learning and watching movies becomes fun
and extremely enjoyable and
efficient that's it for today over and
out